[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشرات الرابعه من الرياض التي نقدموا من
خلالها ابرز اخبارهم ملفات السعوديه
والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
بثلاثه مليارات دولار في البنك المركزي
الباكستاني
وزاره الحج والعمره بدء تطبيق البصمه
الحيويه على القادمين للعمره
الجمارك السعوديه تعلن احباطها محاولتي
تهريب قرابه مليونين ونصف
المليون حبه مخدره
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه كذلك
حذاء الابل والبن الخولاني السعودي ضمن
قائمه التراث الثقافي غير المادي لليونسكو
دوري المجموعات مساء اليوم في المونديال
الكاميرون تبحث عن معجزه امام البرازيل
وغانا للتاهل والثائر من الاردن
حياكم الله اعلن الصندوق السعودي للتنميه
تمديد اجل وديعه بقيمه ثلاثه مليارات
دولار لصالح البنك المركزي الباكستاني دعم
الاقتصاد الباكستاني وتهدف الوديعه
السعوديه الى دعم احتياطي العمله الاجنبيه
في البنك المركزي الباكستاني ومساعده
اسلام اباد في مواجهه التداعيات
الاقتصاديه للجائحه يشار الى انه قد تم
توقيع اتفاقيه الوديعه في نوفمبر من العام
الماضي 2021
نشرت شبكه حقوق الانسان في كردستان مقطع
فيديو جديد لقوات الامن وهي تطلق النار
على عدد من المتظاهرين اثناء عودتهم من
مراسم تشييع اثنين من ضحايا احتجاجاتي
جوان رود في الحادي والعشرين من نوفمبر
[تصفيق]
عقوبه الاعدام سلاح جديد لجا له النظام في
ايران لقمع المتظاهرين بحسب تقارير تحدثت
عنها صحيفه واشنطن بوست اخرها ثلاثه
مراهقين متهمين بجرائم تتعلق بالاحتجاجات
الاخيره قد يواجهون الاعدام
[تصفيق]
تظاهرات حشيده في عده مدن ايرانيه لم تخفض
اصواتها منذ ان بدات
وقودها مواطنون
للشباب والمراهقين وحتى الاطفال
النظام الايراني يدركه حجم المعضله امامه
حلول
بسلاح الاعدام كاداه للقمع السياسيه حسب
صحيفه واشنطن بوست
ثلاثه مراهقين يخضعون للمحاكمه في احدى
ضحى طهران مع عشرات اخرين بتهمه قتل ضابط
شرطه
الاعدام التي تلاحق اولئك المراهقين تاتي
بسبب اتهامهم بجرائم تتعلق بالاحتجاجات
الاخيره
يمثل المراهقون الثلاثه امام المحكمه
الثوريه وهي فرع يختص بالحكم في قضايا
الامن القومي وليس من اختصاصها الفصل في
قضايا الجنائيه ضد القصيرين جماعه حقوقيه
تؤكد ان العقوبات التي طالت المراهقين
تاتي ضمن اطار تسعيدي جديد لحمله وحشيه
الهدف منها ترهيب الشباب من المشاركه في
التظاهرات
حرم المتهمون من مقابله محاميهم وتم
تمثيلهم بدلا من ذلك بمحامين عينتهم
المحكمه
حملت النظام الايراني منذ سبتمبر طالت
اعتقال نحو 18000 شخص
ووجهت اتهامات الى 36 منهم على الاقل
بارتكاب جرائم ما يعاقب عليها بالاعدام
روان حمزه العربيه
عبر مدير الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه
رافائيل روسيا عن امله في التوصل الى
اتفاق مع روسيا واوكرانيا لانشاء منطقه
حمايه في محطه
نوويه قبل نهايه العام الحالي لن يستبعد
عقد لقاء مع رئيس الروسي والاوكراني بخصوص
المحطه في وقت يثير فيه القصف المتكرر حول
اكبر محطه لطاقه النوويه في اوروبا يثيره
قلقا من احتمال وقوي حادثه خطير في تلك
المنطقه
على نادي دفاع روسيه ان قواتها احبطت هجمه
للجيش الاوكراني حول شنها على عده محاور
مؤخرا مكبده الوحدات الاوكرانيه خسائر لدى
عناصر الجيش ومعدته وقت تقريرا للوزاره
التقرير ذكر ان القوه الاوكرانيه خسرت
اكثر من 200 جندي بين قتيل وجريح في محاور
مختلفه شمال لوكانزك واخرى في دونيتسك
بالاضافه الى استسلام 11 جنديا اوكرانيا
على محور كراسي لمن شمالي دونيتسك وفق
الدفاع الروسيه التي قالت ايضا ان قواتها
دمرت العديد من الدبابات الاوكرانيه كما
اسقطت الطائرتين حربيتين وسبعه وسبعه
طائرات مسيره في مناطق قتاليه مختلفه
شرقيه وفق تصريحاتها
تستمر للقوات الروسيه في قصف مدينه خيسون
بعد اضطرارها للانسحاب من المدينه ومحيطها
الى ما وراء نهر دنلوب لكن الحياه عادت
لتسري في شرايين المدينه شيئا فشيئا فيما
لا يزال الخطر قائما
دوريه الاوكرانيه
التي غيرت ملامحها الحرب السكان يخرجون
بحذر للترحيب بالجنود ويطلبون منهم عدم
الرحيل من المدينه التي انقطعت من كل شيء
الا الامل
اوكرانيا ستنتصر سوف نتجاوز اثار الحرب كل
شيء سيصبح على ما يرام ستنتصر قواتنا
المسلحه الاوكرانيه
يرقى لجرائم الحرب حسب احد الضباط
الاوكرانيين
[موسيقى]
تقع هنا انتهاكات للقانون الدولي الانساني
انها جريمه حرب يمكن القول انها ضربات
عشوائيه على البنت التحتيه المدنيه وعلى
المباني
رغم هول الدمار الذي لم يترك حيا او شارعا
لن يطل تبدو المدينه عازمه على اعاده
اعمار احيائها وساحاتها لكن المهمه تبدو
صعبه بدون انتهاء الحرب ومساعده غربيه يصر
الاتحاد الاوروبي على ان تكون روسيا هي من
يتحمل مسؤوليه الاعمار بعد ان تحملت
مسؤوليه الدمار انسنا الناسي العربيه
افادت وسائل الاعلام الافغانيه بيوجع
انفجار في احد المساجد يعتقدوا انه يستهدف
الزعيم الافغاني قلب الدين حكمه المصادر
من محاوله اغتيال فيما قتل اثنين من
المهاجمين بالاضافه الى مقتل احد حراس
حكمه الرئيس
استانف التحالف الدولي بقياده واشنطن
دوريات المعتاده في مناطق سيطره مقاتلين
الاكراد في شمال سوريا بعد تقليصها اثر
الضربات الجويه التركيه على المنطقه ونقلت
فرنسا عن مصدر العسكريين كردي ان الدوري
تراجعت من 20 دوريه اسبوعيه الى نحو خمس
او ست تقريبا بعد ضربات التركيه وحدرت
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه من ان التصعيد
التركي من شانه ان يعرقل حملات ملاحقه
تنظيم داعش التي تقوم بها قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه بالتعاون مع التحالف الدولي
افادت وسائل الاعلام التركيه بوقوع انفجار
واندلاع حريق في ميناء سامسونج المطل على
البحر الاسود في شمال تركيا واشارت الى ان
الحريق اندلع بعد وقوع انفجار باحد صهر
الوقود
رابعه مستمرات تتابعون فيها بعد قليل
حذاء الابل والبن الخولاني السعودي ضمن
قائمه التراث الثقافي غير المادي لليونسكو
حياكم الله من جديد بالعوده الى موضوع
الاول في هذه النشره تمديد صندوق التنميه
السعوديه الوديعه السعوديه في البنك
المركزي الباكستانيه يلتحقوا بها من اسلام
هذا الباب للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه جاسم مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه اولا كيف تنظرون في باكستان
لتوجيه الملك سلمان ولي العهد الامير محمد
بن سلمان تبديده هذه الوديعه لصالح البنك
المركزي الباكستاني واثر هذا التمديد ايضا
نعم هذه خطوه مهمه جدا ناس الوضع
الاقتصادي الباكستاني سيء للغايه نتيجه
الفيضانات مدمره ومؤخرا وايضا نتيجه
قيمه الروبيه مما ادى الى زياده التضخم
المادي المالي وزياده الاسعار وابتداء
الحكومه بشتى المشاكل وهذه طبعا مبادره
كبيره همم
رحبت بها الحكومه الباكستانيه والرئيس
الوزراء السيد شعبان الشريف
وانه همم اجتمع مع القائد السعوديين في
همم
مؤتمر المناخ في شرم الشيخ
واشاده بلقائه همم دون ان يذكر التفاصيل
ولكنه
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
انه متاكد من ان المملكه ستدعم باكستان
قدر الامساك ذكرت قبل قليل بانها باكستان
تمر في ظروف اقتصاديه صعبه وربما يعني بعد
جائحه كورونا بعد الفيضانات ايضا حتى ربما
الازمات الجهه السياسيه الاخيره كانت
باكستان قد تاثرت بجزء مما حدث فيها همم
بالنسبه لباكستان كيف ستساعدها على تخطي
هذه الازمه هذا
التوجيه بتمديد هذه الوديعه كيف ستساعد
الحكومه على تنفيذ بعض المشاريع المهمه او
لهوياتها كذلك في المشاريع سيد جاسم
نعم
الواقع عن
المساعده الكبرى هو تعزيز موقف باكستان
امام صندوق النقد الدولي
لان صندوق النقد الدولي حتى الان غير راضي
على باكستان
وقبل يوم
طلب صندوق النقد الدولي من الحكومه
الباكستانيه
[موسيقى]
لا تتخذ اجراءات كبيره كما طلب صندوق
النقد الدولي
ولكن رئيس الوزراء الشريف امتنع عن ذلك
طاقه شيء اساسي
[موسيقى]
سيد جاسم وصناعيه
يمكن ان نقول بالنسبه
كما انها ايضا ستسهل على الدول الاخرى
التي اعرضت عن استعدادها لمساعده همم
باكستان شريط وانت تتسلم مساعدات من الدول
الاخرى همم
في المنظر
طبعا حتى الان المساعدات
صحيحه بالنسبه من المجتمع الدولي ومن
بالذات من العالم الغربي على الرغم في
قداحه الازمه
والخساره الكبرى التي
واجهتها باكستان لفعل تغيير المناخ وانت
ايضانات
[موسيقى]
المتاثره
التي تشكل حوالي 33
كلها غارقه بالمياه همم
القطب السعوديه خطوه مباركه همم فعلا
ستساهم همم بشكل كبير ايضا همم في تحسين
الوضع
الاقاليم
القيام ببعض المشاريع الاساسيه
المواد الغذائيه سيد جاسم لا يسمعني ربما
لان الاتصال انقطع ايضا معه على كل حال
شكرا جزيلا له من اسلام اباد جاسم تقي
رئيسه معهد الباب للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
اعلانات رابطه العالم الاسلامي عن توقيعها
اتفاقيه شراكه واطلاق المعمل الدولي
للاديان مع جامعه كولومبيا في امريكا يهدف
المعمل العالمي الى بناء القدرات المضاده
لمفاهيم الكراهيه والعنف والصدام الحضاري
وحمايه المجتمعات من اشكال الكراهيه كافه
من نيويورك تنضم الينا مدير التنفيذي
للمعمل الدولي للاديان البروفيسوره امرا
سبيك مرحبا بك معنا في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض دعينا نعرف اولا ما هي فكره هذا
المعمل المعمل الدولي طبيعه الشراكه ايضا
التي وقعت بين رابطه العالم الاسلامي
وكذلك بين جامعه كولومبيا
سنوات
بين الرابطه العالم الاسلامي جامعه
سعاده الدكتور محمد العيسى قبل نحوي سنه
من البوسنه وقد عشته وقلت له اربع سنوات
الكراهيه وقضى عليه كانت مهمتي في الحياه
ونتشاطر هذه المهمه مع سعاده الدكتور محمد
العيسى الامين العام لربطه العالم
الاسلامي وبناء على النقاش الاولي الذي
اجريناها عقدنا عده اجتماعات ادت الى
صياغه هذا
الاول من نوع في العالم الذي يركز اساسا
على مكافحه الكراهيه والعنف في الولايات
المتحده
واعتقد انها سيكون لها اثار دوليه كبيره
مبادره وسطيها بالهائله سيكون لها اثار
ايضا حتى كبيره على ال ال المجتمعات ايضا
ما هي هذه الاثاره المتوقعه ولماذا هذا
المعمل بروفيسوره يعني
اختصا بفكره محاربه الكراهيه وايضا ربما
العنف الصدام الحضاري لماذا ركز على هذه
النقاب تحديدا
في العالم
وهنا في الولايات المتحده في سنتين
الماضيتين عملته بشكل وثيق مع الحكومه
الاتحاديه الامريكيه وزاره الداخليه التي
لها مركز
للشركات وفي السابق تم اطلاق العديد من
المشاري الاساسيه
في الولايات المتحده ومن خلال ارتفاع كبير
في الخطابات الكراهيه والعنف في المدارس
فان حسابات التي تلقى في المدارس يصبح
اشعه عاديه بالنسبه لهؤلاء الاطفال عندما
يكبرون هذا يؤدي الى الكراهيه والحروب
والانقسامات وبالتالي نحن نسعى لتدخل على
مستوى كافه الفئات العمريه وكذلك مع
البالغين والقاده يقومون بدور اساسي لان
خطابات مهمه للغايه ونركز بلاساس على
الفضاء من خلال العمل مع الاطفال
والطلاب من خلال اداه برامج تؤدي الى
تغيير ذهنياتهم وتساعدهم على الايمان
بالقيم الانسانيه المشتركه المتمثله في
الاحترام المتبادل بدلا من نشر الكراهيه
وبغد النظر عن العرق او اللون او الثقافه
او الدين اذن نحن نسعى لكسر هذه الحواجز
من خلال تدخل ومنعي الكراهيه في صفوف
المدرسيه وهنا ياتي سؤال مهم بروفيسوره
لاي مدى هذا ما القادر فعلا على الاسلام
في همم في خفض او حتى هذا
النمو الخطاب الكراهيه خطاب العمر ايضا
همم حتى همم كذلك الذي ذكرته قبل قليل
المستعد
جماعيه وخسرت كل شيء بسبب الكراهيه وعندما
تبقى على قيد الحياه
في ذلك الوقت
العالم الاسلامي وهي الاكبر والاهم لدينا
شارك ايضا مع جامعه كولومبيا وهي من
الاكبر الجامعات المؤثره في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه العالم في
في المدرسيه استاذه لدي طلاب جاءوا من
جميع ارجاء العالم وقد تغيروا بفضل العمل
الذي نقوم به ويمكن لنا ان نحدث فرق وبناء
على البرنامج الذي ننفذه سنحدث الفارق قبل
بدعه سنوات اطلقنا مشروعا شارك فيه طلاب
بيركز بالاساس على
الشعور المناهض للمسلمين في الولايات
المتحده جمعنا البيانات اولا ورايت ان
رحلتي في مجال التعليم في الولايات
المتحده اظهرت لتجارب
فاسو
المواقف المناهده للمسلمين في الولايات
المتحده ومن خلال هذه البيانات التي
جمعناها راينا انه يمكن ان نركز على
الاطفال وكنا بانشاء منهاج لتدريب
المعلمين في الولايات المتحده تعالج
بطريقه مبتكره للغايه هذا الشعور
واستطعنا ان نرى فريقا كبير في ذهني اذا
لدينا
مكونات اساسيان سوف يؤديان الى تحقيق
النجاح من خلال الدعم المؤسسات
والمنظمات العالم
الاسلامي ثم لدينا ادوات البحث وخبره
لدينا التزام وشغفلي احداث الفرق هذا لا
يقتصر علي انا شخصيا ولكن كل من يعمل معي
في هذا الاشراك الجميع ملتزم لمحاربه
الكراهيه سنبذل قصار جهدنا ونحن نؤمن
باننا يمكن ان نحدث الفارق شكرا جزيلا لك
على المشاركه الرابعه من نيويورك
البروفيسوره الامراض
نجحت السعوديه في تسجيل عنصريه حداء الابل
والبن الخولانيه السعوديه في القائمه
التمثيليه للتراث الثقافي غير المادي
والتي تتبع لمنظمه الامم المتحده للتربيه
والعلوم والثقافه يونسكو وبهذا التسجيل
وصل عدد العناصر السعوديه المسجله في
قائمه اليونسكو الى 11 عنصر لتوثيق التراث
السعودي
وتصليط الضوء عليه محليا وعالميا بما يعزز
فرص استمراره
من الرباط تنضمه الينا ابتسام الوهيبي
مدير عام الاداره العامه للتراث الثقفي
غير المادي بهيئه التراث ساد ابتسام مرحبا
بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض ونبارك
لكم اولا هذا التسجيل لحداء الابل البن
الخولاني واريد ان نعرف كيف تمت عمليه
التسجيل المراحل التي مرت بها ايضا
اهلا وسهلا فيك مبروك
يعني لو بحكي عن الخطوات اللي يتم فيها
تسجيل
اكيد من من الوصول الى المجتمعات المحليه
وفهم رغبتهم بنشر اي عنصر من عناصر اللي
يمارسه هنا اكيد عندنا لجنه مختصات تقيم
همم هذه الطلبات وبعدها ينطلق فريق على
ارض الميدان داخل المجتمعات المحليه يتم
همم اجراء الابحاث واخذ المعلومات من
الممارسين لهذه العناصر بعدين يتم جمع كل
المعلومات في همم فورم او استماره هي
استماره تسجيل وتم رفعها للمنظمه بحيث
تقوم لجنه التقييم بالتقييم همم
المعلومات الوارده وبناءا عليه
عنصر طيب الان نحن نتحدث عن عنصر طبعا همم
هذه هي المسجله ماذا عن
العناصر التي على قائمه الانتظار الان متى
من المتوقع ان تنتهي منها ان يتم تسجيلها
ايضا استاذه ابتسام
العديد والمزيد من العناصر احنا الدوره
عندنا تمكننا من تسجيل العنصر واحد في
السنه كعنصر منفرد او عنصر تتميز فيه
المملكه وعنصرين او اكثر كان عناصر
المشتركه اللي هي تكون همم يتم ممارستها
مع الاشقائنا من الدول العربيه او دول
الخليج كما هو الحال مع مع ملف حدائق
الابل
والبن الخولاني كان ملف ااه مشترك لذلك
انتم سجلته
صحيح ملف البن الفلاني كان ملف منفرد
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه وملف حذاءه
بالكم ملف مشترك مع دولتي الامارات
العربيه المتحده وسلطنه عمان
خلينا ايضا اسال عنده هيئه التراث اليوم
في الحراك الثقاف في التراثي ايضا كذلك
الذي تعيشه المملكه في ظل رؤيه 20 30
دوركم اليوم في تسجيل هذه العناصر دوركم
اليوم في البحث عن عناصر ايضا جديده تشجيع
كذلك المجتمعات ال- ال- المحليه كيف يمكن
وصفه
اكيد هو يعني هو انا الدور الهيئه نابعه
اكيد من اهتمام بالقياده بالتراث بشقايا
المادي وغير الماديه احنا عندنا اهداف
استراتيجيه للهيئه منبثقه اكيد من اهداف
وزاره الثقافه اللي هي تتمثل في حمايه
واداره التمكين ابتكار والتطوير
المستداملي مكونات التراث الثقافي اكيد
توثيق اصول التراث الثقافي هي واحده من
الاهداف الاستراتيجيه عندنا وتسجيل اي
عنصر من عناصر التراث يحقق واحد من اهم
مؤشرات الاداء الخاصه برؤيه المملكه عشيره
الثلاثين اللي هي زياده عدد عناصر التراث
الثقافي المسجله على قوائم هذا التسجيل
بالتاكيد يعزز التراث بشكل عام ويحافظ على
الهويه الوطنيه
يعني احنا لدينا عنصر مثل البن الخولاني
اليوم ثم تسجيلها في قائمه التراث غير
المؤدي لدى منظمه مهمه منظمه اليونسكو ما
هو الفرق الذي يحدث بعد ان يتم تسجيله في
هذه
المنظمه الذي تقوم به تترات من دور تجاه
هذا العنصر الذي تسجل
تاكيد اي
تسجيل اللي
ها العنصر المجتمع المحلي اللي تشارك
تشارك في هذا التسجيل وتدعم احنا همم
تسجيلنا لاي عنصر يساهم في ابرازه في
تسليط الضوء عليه وبالتاكيد في صونه في
اداره احنا احنا وقت همم وقت كتابه الملف
لاي عنصر همم اكيد يكون في اجراءات صون
مقترحه لكي يتم همم الحرص على اصتدامات
الممارسه هذه الاجراءات يتم تطبيقها
والحرص على انها تنفذ على ارض الواقع
وبالتاكيد يكون في زياده ورفع للواعي في
المجتمع سواء داخل المنطقه الواحده او همم
في في المملكه بشكل عام خليني اكلمك عن
همم عن تجربتك انت ايضا يمكن يمكن
وانتم دائما يعني بتتناوله المواضيع
تناقشوها يوميا ايضا المجتمعات المحليه
عندما يسجل لديها اي عنصر من عناصر التراث
غير المادي هل يختلف تعطيها مع هذه
العناصر همم هل يختلف ايضا همم بتواصلهم
معكم ايضا او
همم حتى ممارسه همم باي يعني طقوس تشجيعيه
بينهم البين لهذا العنصر الذي بتسجل على
يعني سبيل المثال البني الخولاني مثلا
التسجيل الايه عنصر هو بمثابه الاحتفاء
فيه احنا همم
مثلا لو تكلمنا عنصر البن الخلاني اكيد
المزارعين الموجودين في همم في منطقه جبال
الخلان يكون همم يرفع عندهم الوعي باهميه
همم اهميه الزراعه اهميه المعارف
والممارسات اللي هم يملكونها ويصير عندنا
نواعي اكثر في ال- في ال- في الجهه للناس
باهميتها العنصر يزداد عندنا الاهتمام همم
بتعلم الحرف هذه او الممارسه او اي نوع من
العناصر يتم تسجيلها ويزداد عندنا الوعي
في همم والفضول خلينا نقول في التعرف
عليها في تجربه ممارستها وبالتالي تزيد
عندنا التناقل عندها عبر الاجيال
المناطق يعني اللي تسجل عندها عنصر او
التراث غير همم غير ماده
المعذره ممكن تعيد السؤال انتم لمستوا
الفرق بعد ما تسجلت هذه العناصر في هذه
المجتمعات المحليه
مدير عام الاداره العملي التراث الثقافي
غير المادي بهيئه التراث شكرا جزيلا لك
تعتبر المجالس التراثيه وجهه سياحيه واعده
في مدينه الجبيل الصناعيه شرق السعوديه
تمتاز بطبيعها الخليجي وتعد مقصدا للزوار
من مختلف الجنسيات حيث تجمع ما بين
اللقاءات الثقافيه والاحاديث التي تستثير
الماضي في ذاكره مرتديا المزيد معانا
[موسيقى]
تجارب السياحيه الممتعه تمنحها المجالس
التراثيه في مدينه الجبيل الصناعيه للزوار
والوفود السياحيه التي تحاكي بطبيعتها
الموروث القديمه للبيئه الخليجيه عبد
الرحيم الشريف احد المهتمين بالتراث تعلقه
بالماضي
الذي يحتضر العديد من اللقاءات الثقافيه
ويستقطب الزوار بين الجبيل وخارجها حبه في
التراث هو اللي خلاني اعمل هذا المجلس
طبعا هذا كنت انا احلم فيه من زمان اني
اعمل المجلس التراثي
بالشكل هذا والحمد لله كثير من الزوار يجي
يزور المجلس ويطلع بصوره حلوه
في الماضي والحس في الانتماء اذا دخلنا
المجلس هذا
ويكون في حديث
عن الماضي القديم عن كل قطعه فيها المجلس
معنا الماضي الجبيل القديم
ومنها للتعارف اكثر الناس سواء من السواع
او من المدينه يجون المجلس هذا ويصير في
تعارف يصير فيه همم تبادل ثقافات وافكار
مع بعض
يحتفظوا احمد البويت بنحوي
3,500 من الدلال بمختلف الاحجام والمسميات
يعود تاريخ بعضها الى مائه عام اضافه الى
العديد من القطاع والمقتنيات الاثريه التي
يتزين بها مجلس البويه التراثي احد
المقاصد السياحيه للزوار في مدينه الجبيل
الصناعيه اغلب المقتنعات الذي اخذت السنين
يعني من عمرنا على تجميعها على كده
والاغلب منهم من الجدود طبعا دلال
اعمارها يعني تبتدي من 50 سنه الى 200 سنه
اكثر من 350 دله من اصل 3,500 يمتلكها
الوالد
وعندنا انواع الخناجر باختلاف احجامها
وانواعها وايضا عندنا من انواع المباخر
وايضا نمتلك من بعض السيوف
طبعا كلها قديمه
تضيفوا المجالس التراثيه في مدينه الجبيل
الصناعيه مسارا سياحيا وعدا يحتاجوا الى
المزيد من الدعم والتمكين الا وهو مسار
سياحته التراثيه من الجبيل الصناعيه عالي
اللغبي العربيه
اعلانات وزاره الحج والعمره عن اشتراط
البصمه الحيويه لاصدار تاشيرات العمره
للقادمين من المملكه المتحده والكويت
وماليزيا اضافه الى تونس وبنغلادش الوزاره
واوضحت في بيانها بان تسجيل البصمه
الحيويه اصبح متطلبه للقادمين كما اكدت
بان تسجيل البصمه الكترونيه في المعتمرين
من مراجعه السفرات او مراكز اصدار
التاشيرات بالاضافه الى تسهيل دخولهم عبر
منافذ السعوديه
من الحرم المكي انضم الينا مراسل العربيه
عبد الواحد الحميد عبد الواحد مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
ما لديك من معلومات وتفاصيل حول
معلنت عنه وزاره الحج والعمره فيما يتعلق
بالبصمه الحيويه
نعم نايف اهلا وسهلا بك طبعا فيما يتعلق
بهذا الاشتراط الجديد الذي وضعته وزاره
الحج والعمره بالزام البصمه لهذه الدول
الخمسه يعني من خلال التطبيق الذي وضعته
وزاره الحج والعمره يتم اصدار التاشيرات
التاشيرات العمره بشكل سلس ومن خلال
التطبيق طبعا يتم تصوير همم يعني الواجب
من خلال الجوال باستخدام هذا التطبيق
اضافه الى ادخال بقيه المعلومات وكذلك حتى
يعني همم استخدام همم الكاميرا لتصوير
بصمه همم اليد همم طبعا همم فيما يتعلق
بالحرم المكي نحن نقف الان همم من مدخل
الاجياد في الساحات همم يعني الخارجيه حيث
كما تعلم اليوم هو يوم الجمعه
وكانت هناك اعداد كبيره عده صلاه الجمعه
في المسجد الحرام هناك نايف همم يعني
ازدحام كبير
يعني وكذلك انسيابيه في الحركه في ما
يتعلق بالدخول والخروج للمسجد الحرام من
المداخل الذي التي وضعتها رئاسه شؤون
المسجد الحرام والمسجد النبوي نتحدث عن
اداره الحشود التي تعمل بشكل مستمر على
وضع الاجراءات التي همم تضمن انسيابيه
الحركه نريد ان نتعرف على ابرز هذه
الاجراءات ينضم الينا سلمان المطرفي وهو
من اداره الحشود اهلا وسهلا بك سلمان نريد
ان نعرف يعني ما هي ابرز الاشتراطات اللي
وضعتوها بشكل عام الاشتراطات همم التصريح
العمره هذا من همم السرطان تم رئاسه
الحرمين تم تسخير كافه المداخل للمعتمرين
ونصلين
[موسيقى]
طيب في ما يتعلق سلمان بيه يعني حتى
المداخل والمخارج اللي وضعتوها
للدخول والخروج من المسجد الحرام تحديدا
في يوم الجمعه اااه وتم وضع خطه في يوم
الجمعه
بوضعه الرئاسه شلون الحرمين جميع الخدمات
لاستقبال الحشود في يوم الجمعه طيب سلمان
يعني اخيرا ملامح بشكل عام خطتكم بشكل عام
في الدخول والخروج باذن الله
مع
تحت اشراف الجهات المسؤوله باذن الله
ناجحه باذن الله شكرا جزيلا لك سلمان
المطرف في اداره الحشود برئاسه شؤون
المسجد الحرام والمسجد النبوي نايف يعني
كما تعلم هناك مداخل متعدده المسجد الحرام
همم يعني من الجهات الاربعه يتم من خلالها
تنظيم دخول الزوار والمعتمرين الى المسجد
الحرام تحديدا في يوم الجمعه زي الشكر من
الحرم المكي بين مراسل العربيه مستمر
اختتام دوري المجموعات مساء اليوم في
مونديال قطر الكاميرون تبحث عن معجزه امام
البرازيل وغانا للتاهل والثاني من
الارغواي
اعلنت الجمارك السعوديه يعني احباط
محاولتي تهريب اكثر من مليونير و400,000
حبه كبتاجون عبر ميناء جدا ومنفذ الربع
الخالي كما اعلنت عن القبض على سته اشخاص
المتورطين في القضيه
[موسيقى]
نختم الرابعه بابرز عناوينها
الصندوق السعوديه للتنميه يعلن تمديد
وديعه بثلاثه مليارات دولار في البنك
المركزي الباكستاني
وزاره الحج والعمره تعلن بدء تطبيق البصمه
الحيويه على القادمين للعمره من خمس دول
الجمارك السعوديه تعلن احباط محاولتي
تهريب قرابه مليونين ونصف المليون حبه
مخدره
حذاء الابل والبن الخولاني السعودي ضمن
قائمه التراث الثقافي غير المادي لليونسكو
اكتتاموا دوري المجموعات مساء اليوم في
مونديال قطر الكاميرون تبحث عن معجزه امام
البرازيل وغان للتاهل من الاوروجواي
نهايه
[موسيقى]